40 games left in the regular season of the wild
thrilled to get Jonas Brodin back on the blue
line he had missed the last 17 for Minnesota Mark
Andre flurry gets the call between the pipes here
are the Northland Ford starting goenda flurry
I mean he gosh he can run through his stats
and everything else and that's not as impressive
as probably his ability to play good hockey in a
stretch with the team out in front of him hasn't
been great he's been the Wild's best player over
this tough stretch of hockey no question about
it for me got s in the net last game out gave
up five Mark Andre flor's the better goal tender
he gets this opportunity here in an early game
Monday night Minnesota trying to snap a losing
streak on home ICE they've dropped their last
six here comes capriso in capriso for a shot and
a shoulder save by sokin that deflex up and out
of play from Matt zukar to Carill capric off and
he just pulls this through finds the triangle on
they've got no points to give up and surrender
so they've just been riding their number one
poke checks this away barzel drops it back
to leave for a shot and a save by flurry
they haven't been dictating the aggressiveness
the urgency and there Mark Andre flurry makes
the save and boom hey you know what I'm
going to be out there on top of my paint
Le I think sometimes teams can be guilty
of just kind of resting on their Laurels
a little bit when some of their star players
come back but that's where the start to this
game has been encouraging absolutely in the
Islanders with a bunch on there I mean kak
poo to he probably has five of his 600 points in
an Islander sweater Mike Riley's joined this club
recently Riley lays across to the near side
for inal back to Riley inal a drive pad save
flurry Riley wraps it off the boards and out to
Center Martin fire saved by flurry rebound loose
Dobson into the slot Roman of a shot shot saved
by flurry rebound was loose for a moment flurry
reaching for it still no whistle and the puck goes
to the wall Riley plays it in Pou works out from
behind the n a shot saved by flurry rebound
Holstrom get something on [Applause] [Music]
that Nelson races into the Minnesota
Zone h checked away harvat a shot and
a save by flurry Nelson just
trying to make something out
of nothing and the puck Finds Its way
everybody on the wild bench standing
up the win for flurry will
be number five 52 in his
[Applause]
career Patrick W as we've talked about so many
times his hero as a youngster pelet fires wide
final seconds and there it is a shut out
for flurry for [Music] [Applause] [Music]
552 win Wild Mark Andre flry has passed
Patrick you make it argument that it could
be the other 19 guys that have wanted this
win for Mark Andre flurry more than Mark
Andre flurry has but nonetheless tip of the
cap to him 552 looks good on you Mark Andre
congratulations second all time passes Patrick W
celebration ensues in the corner pretty emphatic
blocker fist pump from him as well sole
possession second place most wins all time
21 save shut out to move past W well Mark Andre so
much fun to watch you compete number 552 tonight
in the win column how good does this feel thank
you thank you uh jeez I'm glad glad it's over you
glad we was going to stop talking about it but
um you know it's about time we we get that one
but uh an honor honor to to be here in Minnesota
you know for the fans and you know been great all
night so that was a that was awesome and to do it
at home you mentioned the fans this is a hockey
loving Market they not only love the game but they
know the history of the game they know what this
moment means how special is it for you to do it
at home in front of these fans yeah definitely you
know it's such a special moment for me you know
for my family um all the years the sacrifice and
stuff you know so um honor honor to do it here
with you guys and my my teammates in the room
too little cherry on top of the Sunday is the
shutout number seven 74 in your career when did
you start thinking about the the number 552 late
in the game and then maybe finishing it off right
with the goose egg uh didn't want JX myself so I
didn't think too much about the goose X but uh I
was just happy to get a win you know it's been a
little rough lately and guys are fighting hard you
know trying to get some wins here and um you know
fighting get some players back you know getting
healthy again and um you know I just happy to get
a win and how much can this help the team got a
tough road trip ahead to get a win like this where
you guys look like the team that rattled off out
of 14 when John Hines got here yeah definitely uh
you know D is a good team right and I thought we
uh we had the pocket lot we didn't give him
much right we we did take the play right so
if we can keep playing that way you know beinging
loose playing fast I think we'll be in good shape
I'm so very happy for you congratulations thank
you guys thank you go Mark Andre flurry awesome
on the ice better off it tonight he walks
into the record books with win number 552